yes um so josh also did musical theater
as a kid um we both actually did
not many people know this but josh was a
guest on the pilot episode of the show
because he's super cool and nice and
totally came and did me a solid
but we talked about our musical theater
backgrounds and we realized something
strange as we talked take a look
i remember thinking though when i first
was introduced to musical theater oh
we're just all cool with like
they're just she's just gonna break out
in song like as if it's normal like
she's just like talking and that's the
thing i'm feeling a song so i'm just
gonna do that
i kind of thought that was awkward it is
awkward and people who are sometimes a
little weird about
is it me or is it just the way he smiles
that leaves me breathless
how can i not tell her that i love her
so like adina menzel that is crazy crazy
crazy she is you got to tour with adina
menzel
we're right i mean she got the tour of
joshua no no
to together she is um truly oh you're
about to we're about to hit the road i
thought you just no
no we're about to do it no she's just
unbelievable you know what you know how
it is
and all at once my
life starts to have meaning
and all that works i can't ever
look back
but crazy that y'all are going to be
there at the same time right because
like same time
you're going to get to sing let it go
well i don't know i mean she i mean she
sings let it go and i just listen i'll
just go back and listen to you i like to
hear you seeing like
i would like to hear myself sing let it
go but you know what sometimes you just
got to let those dreams go
sometimes seeing let it go in the shower
best reverb of all time
i finally found him i finally found her
hello
it is so great i just adore you i
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i love you so much for doing that i just
remembered after watching that
he literally learned that right before
we did it like we
i we we put that together right before
we did it and you were so
gay well you only gave me one line i
mean it was really it was whatever
and look you've you've you've uh you've
you've graduated from stools to look at
this beautiful couch and look and i have
a band now like a full band
it's all amazing we could do it look
what you helped me oh no listen
it was an honor to be there then and it
is now